the americans have closed all the gates
access
medics rushing from the next casualty to
the next
it looks like death to me this is
because we left these people in charge
these barbarians are in charge we are no
longer in charge over there apparently
the leadership of the democratic party
they just don't care very much i'm not
sure how else to read their activities
this weekend
you had nancy pelosi off in napa valley
dining with the dccc and you had chuck
schumer dancing it up with stephen
colbert
in new york city this was kind of an
astonishing tape given the fact that
there are currently thousands of
american citizens stuck in kabul and the
senate majority leader is dancing it up
with stephen colbert according to the
new york post
senate senator chuck schumer was ripped
on twitter for dancing with stephen
colbert backstage at the we love nyc
concert amid the ongoing catastrophe in
afghanistan and as the coronavirus
pandemic continues to surge across the
u.s backstage antics wrote mayor de
blasio's press secretary bill nye heart
in a twitter posting on saturday before
the star-studded concert in central park
was abruptly canceled because of storms
and lightning generated by hurricane re
so it's uh yeah god was like no and uh
and thus was the we love nyc
celebration cancelled here was a little
bit of um some incredibly awkward
dancing between the senate majority
leader and a man who used to be funny at
one point stephen colbert although it's
been a long time it's hard to remember i
know
[Music]
it's just a disaster area not just the
dancing not just the dancing backstage
between stephen colbert
whose job it is to target politicians
and uh and chuck schumer the senate
majority leader it's just it's wonderful
wonderful stuff happening meanwhile
thousands of americans are still stuck
in kabul with no way out and now
the taliban are openly mocking us so
they put up a photo
of their guys raising a taliban flag in
the same exact formation
as the marines on iwo jima in world war
ii
according to the marine corps times in
one particular image released this week
members of the taliban badri 313
battalion appeared to mock joe
rosenthal's iconic 1945 image of the
flag raised atop mount suribachi during
the battle of iwo jima in the taliban
image fighters belonging to badri 313
which some are calling the taliban's
elite commando unit are shown wearing
full camouflage uniforms combat boots
tactical gear and night vision goggles
similar photographs released in recent
days show taliban fighters carrying
weapons and equipment issued by the
united states or allied nations
including m4 carbines and what appear to
be trijicon advanced combat optical gun
sights or acogs
the images are noticeable departure from
traditional depictions of taliban
fighters who seldom appeared with heavy
weaponry or in full military garb spoils
left behind by the afghan army so things
are going really well they're going even
better than that actually it turns out
that over at the airport
a fox news reporter is suggesting lucas
tomlinson that the taliban have been
stepping up attacks on afghans outside
abigail kabul airport they've been
tearing up passports and other vital
documents one afghan trying to escape
says the taliban knocked his wife's
teeth out at a checkpoint which of
course is no shock at all
you have to understand that the kabul
airport you think of an airport as like
a big place with a lot of runways kabul
airport is not a big place with a lot of
runways kabul airport is a postage stamp
bagram airport which we
ridiculously surrendered to the taliban
for no apparent reason was a very large
airport kabul is one runway
literally one all the taliban have to do
to knock out the ability of anyone to
fly anything out of afghanistan at this
point is send one mortar around into the
runway that's it and everybody knows
this which is why they are treating the
taliban with kid gloves meanwhile the
taliban are basically screening whoever
goes through the checkpoint the security
and this has resulted not just in
afghans being targeted but also in
americans being targeted as well lloyd
austin the secretary of defense he
admitted over the weekend that americans
are basically being beaten by the
taliban as they approach these
checkpoints
if you have uh an american passport and
if you have the right credentials the
taliban has been allowing people to uh
to to pass safely through not in all
cases
there's no such thing as an absolute in
this kind of environment as you would
imagine uh martha there there have been
incidents of uh people uh you know
having some some tough encounters with
with taliban as we learn about those uh
incidents we certainly go back and
engage the taliban leadership and and uh
and press home to them
that our expectation is that they allow
uh you know our people with uh with the
appropriate
credentials to get through the
through the checkpoints oh well you know
as long as we're as long as we're
conveying our feelings to the taliban
obviously that will change things by the
way the state department guidance right
now is utterly unclear they're basically
saying we can't guarantee your safety to
get to the airport you should wait until
we get back to you and give you
instructions but also don't call us
because we're overwhelmed
so it remains a complete crap show over
in kabul
meanwhile tony blinken is trying to
explain that the best way to get to the
kabul airport is to go yourself we're
not going to be sending soldiers out
there the way that the british have with
the italians have like there are other
people who are out there what the
ukrainians have like they're sending
their military into the city to go pick
up their citizens and bring them back
but apparently not the united states
tony blinken is saying basically you
have to get there yourself and we'll try
to figure out a way to get you out but
we can't guarantee your safety getting
there but also we're not going to come
get you so imagine for a second that you
were now you were an american stuck in
afghanistan what would you do at this
point would you try to brave the
thousands of people who are now
surrounding the kabul airport including
taliban fighters to get through there
let's say you're an american woman and
you're trying to get through how would
this go for you do you feel perfectly
comfortable that you would get through
the phalanx of taliban fighters and
barbarians who are now guarding the
airport tony blinken says well you know
we're doing our best
the best way the most effective way the
way i'm focused on to get folks in again
is to be in direct contact with them uh
and to help guide them in to give them
instructions on where to go uh when to
go there
and then we can we can bring them into
the airport safely and effectively so
they are still effectively on their own
getting to the airport
uh
again uh we found that the the best way
to do this is to be in direct touch with
them
president secretary of defense have been
clear that uh we will uh do whatever it
takes to get americans uh home and and
out of harm's way oh you'll be in touch
with them you see you'll talk them
through it um
yes i'm sure that as people hear stories
about people having the crap beat out of
them by the taliban their first thought
is well probably i'm just going to go
there you know i mean like what's what
could be the harm exactly meanwhile jake
sullivan the national security adviser
he had missed there's still several
thousand americans trying to get out of
kabul now remember none of this counts
presumably the hundreds or thousands of
americans who are not in kabul right
this is just the americans who are in
kabul but they're americans that ngos
all over afghanistan
a lot of those people ain't coming home
a lot of and i promise you a year from
now there can be videos of americans in
afghanistan or being held hostage by the
taliban
if you think that american involvement
in afghanistan ended with joe biden
declaring that american involvement in
afghanistan is over uh
just watch the news for the next year or
so here's jake sullivan
exactly how many americans are left
behind in afghanistan
well nora the u.s government doesn't
actually know the precise answer to that
question and that's because we ask every
american who comes to afghanistan to
register with the u.s embassy but when
people leave they often don't
de-register and even some who come never
register in the first place well the
clock is ticking the deadline is
approaching it's just 12 days away you
think you can have all that buttoned up
by then
we can move thousands of people every
single day between now and the end of
the month we have plenty more seats on
flights than we believe that there are
possibly americans still in afghanistan
yeah yeah so they have no idea how many
people are actually there
meanwhile fox news is trey yingst he
says there is no clear plan in place to
rescue the americans or outside of kabul
because remember again not all of the
americans are in kabul
the question we keep hearing whether
it's people reaching out online saying
we have relatives or friends trapped in
kabul or elsewhere
they keep asking what's the plan have
you heard anything who can i contact to
make sure that my loved ones get to the
airport
and
while there is a limited plan to get
countries including the united states on
the ground here to evacuate those who
can make it to the airport there is no
clear plan in place
to save the thousands of americans who
are not only spread out around kabul but
in other cities
kandahar smaller cities around the
country and they have no way to get here
all of this because joe biden decided to
precipitously pull out with no warning
right with that without really any plan
and he said we were gonna pull out april
14th but he didn't start actually
evacuating people so instead we just
moved the military out and we left all
the materiel and human beings behind
which is precisely the opposite of what
you would do even if you're in favor of
the withdrawal which again i think is is
politically foolish i think it's
geostrategically idiotic but even if
you're in favor of the withdrawal even
if you think that this is something that
had to be done we may as well do it
sooner rather than later you at least
have to leave the soldiers in there long
enough to make sure that we get our
stuff and people out instead we just
handed our military technology over to
the taliban we abandoned our air bases
we completely hit we basically cut our
own hamstrings so we can't actually
effectuate
a way of getting people out of there
to the point where now
we not only do we not have an ability to
get people out of there the biden
administration is openly at this point
talking about bombing
all of the people and and resources that
we left there so the idea is we left all
of these military resources behind maybe
we should bomb them
maybe we should just blow up all the
military resources
according to axios the biden
administration is considering launching
airstrikes against the larger equipment
they fear that such a move could provoke
the taliban at a time when the u.s is
focusing on evacuating people from
afghanistan again this is because we
left these people in charge these
barbarians are in charge we are no
longer in charge over there
according to politico in the chaos of
the moment it's unclear to u.s officials
how much equipment the taliban has
seized and how much of that sits
unattended on bases and in small combat
outposts across the country that
uncertainty over the status of a massive
arsenal is sparking fears of a regional
arms bazaar that could be a boon to
terrorist groups and insurgents
the images that have spread across the
world over the past week of taliban
fighters posing in front of captured
helicopters and light attack a craft
light attack aircraft have allowed the
group to further humiliate the former
afghan and american government but these
images don't concern long-time extremism
watchers as much as the proliferation of
guns at bullets and grenades
so now i guess we're gonna have to send
troops back in to blow all that stuff up
so this has been just wonderful cnn
meanwhile reporting there really is no
access to the airport
the americans have closed all the gates
access there is no access to
the airport at the at the moment except
through one a british access point
called camp baron which is on the
outskirts of the airport where people
are processed there and then
moved into the airport once they've been
cleared to fly out now that has been the
case now for many hours that is sam
kiley of cnn reporting as of yesterday
sky news also reporting on the chaos and
saying yeah no things are not organized
out here
this is an emergency now
it's nothing to do with process they're
just trying to save lives
tens of thousands trying to get through
at the front they're being
crushed paratroopers pulling people from
the mayhem
medics rushing from the next casualty to
the next and the next the soldiers spray
the crowd with a hose anything to cool
them down
men women
and
[Music]
and then what we feared the inevitable
is this a stabilized withdrawal from
afghanistan
it looks like death to me
okay so that is a report from sky news
things going great though according to
the biden administration by the way
there have been at least 20 deaths in
the last week during the kabul airport
evacuation effort according to nato
that's how well things are going over
there
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed